林黛玉是红楼梦里成长痕迹最明显的一位金差。其他金差的人物性格为人处事,基本都是固定的。唯独林黛玉前期雕尊古怪,到了后期变得温柔可人。这也导致许多读者对林黛玉的评价,居于一种缺乏全局关的偏见。
义言已必知,林黛玉表面上雕尊刻薄,但本质上是谨慎小心的。尤其是她对自己和宝玉关系的深刻洞察,简直可用如旅博兵来形容。
红楼第57回,也就是读者非常熟悉的,汇子捐,情词是忙寓。子捐为了试探宝玉对待遇的心意,故意骗说待遇,不日就要回孤苏,引得宝玉渡入梦言状态。
而这场风波的起源,却是因为一件小事。便是林黛玉为了避惠男女之防,主动跟甲宝玉保持距离,
也让宵香馆的压患跟甲宝玉保持距离,原住记。
宝玉身手向子捐身上摸了一摸,说,穿这样单宝,子捐便说道,从此咱们只可说话,别动手动脚的,一年大二年小的,叫人看着不尊重。
打紧的那起混帐杭子们,被帝里说你,你总不流行,还只管和小时一般行为,如何使得。
姑娘常常吩咐我们,不叫和你说笑,你进来瞧他远着你,还恐远不及呢。说着便起身,写了真线,进别防去了。
宝玉见了这般景况,心中呼交了一盆冷水一般。
甲宝玉受了这场冷落,一个人作于时尚发呆,子捐担心他生病,这才过来探望,一时动了心死,三言两语骗了宝玉,闹出事与风波。
很多学者在分析林代玉形象时,总会列举这个例子,以证明林代玉走上了成熟路线。
布红君认为,这个说法不完全正确。林代玉对男女之防的洞察并不是从第五时期回开始,诸君若是不信,且听布红君一一举例。
援助第32回,使乡云劝甲宝玉立身正道,甲宝玉趁怒道,林姑娘何曾说过这样的话,却被窗外驻族的待遇听道,操却请记待遇反应为,所惊者他在人前一片思心撑扬与我,其亲热厚密尽不必嫌疑。
第34回,不叫种种大成吃踏之后,甲宝玉重伤臥床,
令秦文送两块旧怕给待遇,待遇收到后心中自私,再乡宝玉令人思乡传递于我又可惧。
其可惧之处就在于,男女思乡传递若让外人知道,后果不堪设想,嫌言碎语时难断矩。
第45回,风语西闷志风语词,甲宝玉入夜批缩待遇而来,看望生病的待遇。
宝玉走后,待遇深夜难以入睡,急思考内容为,一面又想宝玉,随素习河沐终有嫌疑。
又听见窗外,竹烧焦野之上,与生息泥,亲含透沐,不觉有低下泪来。
结合这些例子不难看出,临待遇从很早就绝查到了男女之房的问题。
甲宝玉反而吸力呼突,一直不把这个机会放在心上。
故而,房间闲谈说,男性的心里成熟,往往比女性妖碗的多,此言不讲。
临待遇的忧律是有道理的。
墓下红学界解读宝玉待遇结局,有一种猜测就认为,墓石英元的最终破产,原子围绕着甲宝玉和临待遇的谣言。
有可能是赵一娘从中使坏,墓地是败坏甲宝玉的名声。
这种猜测是否正确,我们赞钱按下。
但妖言一起确实是实。
因为第五十七回,子捐明确告诉宝玉。
那起混帐行字们被帝地说你,你总不流行,还知管和小时一般行为如何使得。
另有第七十七回,秦文遭年,甲宝玉偷偷探望,恰遇见秦文之嫂多姑娘。
多姑娘便拉着宝玉要允语一番,见宝玉言词围碗拒绝,多姑娘便说。
既然等着了你,虽然文明不如见面,空长了一个好模样,
尽是没要性的炮长,只好装黄子霸了,倒比我还发山怕羞,可知人的嘴已改听不得的。
就比如方才我们姑娘下来,我也料定你们素日偷鸡道狗的。
我进来一会儿再窗下细听,屋内只你二人,若有偷鸡道狗的事,其由不谈急于此。
谁知你两个,尽还是个不相扰,可知天下委屈事也不少,如今我反后悔错怪了你们。
多姑娘之所以要跟甲宝玉常识一番,就是在外面听说,甲宝玉是个风月常中的老手,天天跟姐妹压患们私混在一起。
因是个后色烂银之人,等真见了甲宝玉,才发现这一切都是误传。
其实和指书中人,包括今天许多不明就离者,他们或许从未看过红楼梦。
一听说,红楼讲的是,甲宝玉和一群女孩的故事,便眼足滴溜溜乱转,随后一生尖笑,似乎早已动茶此书底里。
将甲宝玉视为西门庆一类,官此不易背乎。
天下如多姑娘者不少,天下如多姑娘般,会见真相者却不多。
作为举中人的灵代玉,她早已敏锐的觉察到这层危机。
这才有第五十七回,待玉主动跟甲宝玉保持距离,并盯主自家压缓,不可跟甲宝玉过于亲密。
单以此行为来看,待玉的成熟远高于甲宝玉。
原住第六十二回,甲宝玉和灵代玉一论探村管家,待玉对探村雷利风行的举动赞赏不已,
并对甲家内部经济危机表示了担忧,可甲宝玉仍旧还是那个天真单纯的男孩,我们来看原住此段。
宝玉道,你不知道呢,你病着时,她干了好几件事,这原子也分了人管,如今多架一槽也不能了。
又捐了几件事,单拿我和凤姐姐做法子进别人,最是心里有算计的人,待玉道,要这样才好,咱们家里也太花费了,
我虽不管是,心里每长闲了,替你们一算计,出得多,进得少,如今若不省结,必置后手不接。
宝玉笑到,凭她怎么后手不接,也短不了咱们两个人的。
待玉听了,转身旧往听上寻宝猜,说笑去了。
宝玉已经开始思考未来的路,家宝玉还在做吃山空,所以宝玉说完话之后,待玉甚至没有回答她,直接转身去找宝猜说话,可能待玉也清楚。
券说家宝玉只能招职她的反感,不如沉默最好。另有第79回,秦文去世后,家宝玉做服容女儿累计电。
林耽玉夸占累文写的几秒,可以曹俄卑鄙尼。
两人探讨了一会儿,潜词用句,下职二杰甲营村即将出价,夫家来甲府拜遇。
王夫人命人叫甲宝玉过去见课,待玉变劝宝玉去忙正景事,结果两人的观念再次发生冲突。
待玉到,快去干正景事吧,才刚太太打发人叫你明儿一走,快过大舅母那边去。
你二姐姐已有人家求准了,想是明儿那家人来拜运,所以叫你们过去呢。
宝玉拍手到,何必如此忙,我身上也不大好,明儿还未必能去呢。
待玉到,又来了,我劝你把脾气改改吧,一年大二年小。
一面说话一边咳嗽起来,宝玉忙到,这里风冷,咱们只顾待站在这里,快回去吧。
待玉到,我也家去歇息了,明儿再见吧,说着便自取路去了。
我们对比第62第79回,这两次待玉对宝玉的劝书是寻许见尽的。
第62回时,待玉虽然不喜欢宝玉的说法,但也没有当面反对,直接转身去找宝差说话。
第79回时,待玉已经开始反薄宝玉了,劝她改改脾气,不要再耍以前的小孩子信了。
而且只劝了一半,就被一阵咳嗽打断了。
最后也是待玉自己取路而走。
很显然,曹卓卿是在塑造假宝玉的黎晶判斗。
通过西日从不劝书的临待玉,展示年龄见长,大家都需要未未来谋话的现实。
借由待玉的劝书,带出宝玉的故质,也为假宝玉最后选牙撒手顿入空门埋下了福笔。
也就是说,坊间所盛传的,假宝玉如果取了临待玉,就不会顿入空门。
这种说法显然是孩童思维,企图将爱情当成阻止假宝玉顿物的解药。
熟捕之,宝玉的大测大物是任何人都无法阻拦的。
第62回,待玉没有说话,第79回,待玉的劝书被咳嗽打断。
以此关之,是否帮是回之后,待玉对宝玉的劝书就会成为常态。
一旦待玉也开始劝书,那么便真的成了职验宅所说的拆待议题。
假宝玉的结局便也是定书,一切都无法改变。
临待玉也救不了这位长不大的贵公子。
今天的红楼解读就到这里,我们下个视频再会。